Monique is with us to start off this
hour in Los Angeles I'm Monique how are
you hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay I'm calling
because I finished baby step one was
saved my thousand awesome Reggie's fun
and I'm trying to step into baby step
two but I'm nervous because I'm such a
saver so I've been able to say but about
60 $26,000 how much 20,000 $26,000 great
okay in what just didn't I'm a savings
account yes they're just imaginable
savings account and I have about forty
eight thousand depth so fourteen comes
in my car and about thirty four comes
from student debt and I know I have the
money to pay for off the car but I guess
I'm just going to figure how do I step
into that I'm just so nervous about
putting any of the money just because I
want to use it as like a safety net in
case anything happens but I do know I
need to hear it just intercept two and
just go for it don't you are you single
yes what do you make a year any one
thousand good for you well done what do
you do for a living I'm a counselor okay
good good
well if you keep doing counselor you
know this okay what you've been doing
you're gonna keep getting what you've
been getting agreed yeah okay if you
believe that then when you're talking to
you're one of the people you're
counseling about trying a different
behavior pattern a different way to
solve a problem than they've used before
but it's scary because I've never done
it before how do they get past that how
do you help somebody get past that I
just pretty much done with their end
goal and I know my angles to be
debt-free so why do you want be
debt-free because there's a lot of
things that I want to do and I want to
start eventually saving up for a house
because I'm kidding around that time and
so I can't do that if I have this car
loan just sitting there and I have this
money not really doing anything and if I
pay off all my best and I have more to
invest and then you know to me why would
you want to invest more just for my
retirement and also being able to put
some more special way to get a down
payment on the house you pay off the
house someday right yeah so can I could
I correct you gently and say your end
goal is not debt free your goal is to be
debt-free so that your
in goal is to build wealth yeah so the
shortest distance between you and wealth
is to be debt-free so that you can use
your income to get you a home and you
can use your income to build wealth and
your retirement funds agreed yeah
and so what's the shortest distance that
free not a 2% savings account with
security associated with it yeah but
there is a bit of a tightrope here yeah
I mean we're walking across the swinging
bridge over the over the ravine because
you're single and you've been broke
before and it scares you I know the
feeling I've been scared too you know
those swinging bridges you know what I'm
talking about when you take your whole
twenty six thousand dollars and you
plunk it down on your car and your
student loans and a home my goodness
takes your breath away you feel like
you're yeah that would be folly with
nothing underneath me did so is it
better I just pay off my car because I
mean I couldn't pay off the car but I
still I wouldn't have enough to pay off
the student loan so should I just do the
fourteen thousand in car and then do as
much as I can okay let me give you two
answers answer number one is what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes and
what we recommend in the Total Money
Makeover book is throw the whole twenty
six thousand dollars at your dad which
would be pay off the car have a thousand
dollars in the account that scares you
to death you can't even breathe with me
saying it right okay I understand I got
you I got you I got your back I'll catch
you when you fall it's okay so anyway
you're not gonna pass out too bad here
on the radio so we're gonna pay off the
car and then we would throw the other
twelve thousand dollars at the thirty
four thousand dollar student loan having
twenty two thousand dollars left how
fast you're gonna pay off twenty two if
you're making seventy one better years
some change how about six months oh okay
yeah that's two thousand bucks um two
thousand bucks a month does it in a year
three thousand bucks a month does it in
six months that's probably more you
probably do yeah because you got you're
not doing anything else right now you're
not going out to eat you're not going on
vacation because we have a big goal the
big goals be debt-free so that we can
buy a house so that we can fund our
retirement so that we can retire with
dignity and change our family tree you
got a big goal that's bigger than eat
now
going on vacation right now agreed yes
agreed okay so that's the answer is what
I would do now what are you likely to do
because this is freaking you out
I gotta at least talk into paying off
the car today oh yeah yeah the car
definitely I just wasn't sure about the
extra extra I would throw at it but if
you're dying over this let me tell you
what you can do mm-hmm you can leave
that other 13 or 12 sitting there what
is it 12,000 sitting there yeah and you
could pay down on the student loan until
it gets to 12,000 and then pay it off
okay then you would be good on it right
now hundred seven you shouldn't be you
should be paying it all on the car right
now because you're working the debt
snowball right now okay smallest debt
gets all the attention till it's gone
but we're gonna go ahead and pay that
off okay and then I want you to get this
student loan down to 12,000 and then I
want you to pull that other last 12,000
out and pay it off okay
at least do that one yeah but the best
route is what I told you earlier because
let me tell you what will happen if you
do what I told you to do in the first
option it's gonna scare the crud out of
you and you're gonna be so focused
because you want to get that savings
built back up true and it's gonna cause
you to knock that student loan in the
mouth mm-hmm you gonna get with it cuz
you're gonna go I don't live I don't
like living with no money I'm getting
rid of student loan because effectively
mathematically what you've done is
you've admitted how broke you are when
you pay that down because you feel like
you're not broke right now and you are
you have a negative net worth today so
you're broke by definition you make good
money and you're a smart lady so it's
time to move to the next step so those
are your two answers you can do it
either way you won't do it I'm not gonna
be mad at you but if you wanted to
follow what we teach you would just
chunk it down on both and be debt-free
in about six months and then build your
emergency fund back up you'd be just
fine you're gonna be okay that bridge
across the ravine lots of people have
been across it it hadn't fallen yet it's
not gonna fall on you you're gonna make
it lots of people have trusted that
bridge and it's but it's scary if you
look down I mean it's like way down
there Tarzan ain't going even survive
that puppy so you know I mean you just
really it scares the crud out of you I
get it but that's how we do see the
thing you use is you use a little bit of
hangar use a little bit of fear he's a
little bit I'm disgusted I make
too much money to be this freakin broke
see how that anger building up that's
good anger there's good fear and there's
good anger good fear keeps you from
playing in the interstate where trucks
are driving keeps you from touching hot
stoves causes you to move fast through
your debts so that you can build the
emergency fund
that's good fear positive things causes
you to move your butt hey you got you
got this money q call me back if I can
help I got I'm proud of you you're gonna
do it